[Music]
hey you guys time for another tomes of
terror book review and again i'm doing
another one that uh is actually free to
read on kindle unlimited if you have a
kindle unlimited membership
this one
man i can't believe that it has taken me
this long this is another one of those
authors uh just like michael mcdowell
who's an american author
that it just took me an embarrassingly
long time to get around to
uh this is a writer named graham joyce
and he was a british writer he sadly
passed away in 2014 of cancer uh died
actually fairly young he was only 59
years old
but he's written several several novels
as well as like a [ __ ] ton of short
stories and he'd won like all kind of
awards and for whatever reason he just
never um you know he was never on my
radar and now that he is i'm just kind
of like where the [ __ ]
how could i not have known like who this
guy was because i really really like uh
i mean this book in particular actually
i was um
reading some reviews of this where uh
someone who had met the author uh you
know before he died obviously asked like
which of your many novels should i start
with and uh the author himself
apparently recommended this one this is
called the tooth fairy
now
i know that there was a movie there's
probably more than one but i know there
was kind of like a horror movie that was
called the tooth fairy that came out in
2006 this book is nothing to do with
that
interestingly though
uh this book actually came out in 1996
it was his fifth novel i believe
and it was actually optioned for a movie
um and i think he did write a screenplay
and or actually like wrote a couple
versions of a screenplay for it um and i
think a couple of of his other novels
were optioned as well but as far as i'm
aware as of this recording i don't think
any of his novels have been made into
movies and that really um kind of needs
to be rectified like right now because
this was
a great [ __ ] i loved this book so
much and this was another one that i
just like sat and read entirely in one
sitting like the whole time going like
how did i never hear of this guy before
it's like it's it's a crime i don't know
where i've been where i've been i've
just been sleeping on it so
i will say though
this um and this apparently is true of
like a lot of uh graham joyce's stuff
his writing is not
super classifiable in the sense that it
usually falls into
the wide umbrella of fantasy dark
fantasy that kind of thing
but a lot of his stuff is really you
can't really put it you know you can't
really get a handle on exactly what
genre it is
and this book the tooth fairy is no
exception it's usually marketed as
horror
which
it is to an extent
but it's more like
a magical realism coming of age story
with a lot of kind of dark aspects to it
kind of like
kind of gave me the same kind of vibe as
like boy's life by robert mccammon or
you know stephen king's the body uh you
know that stand by me was based on you
know ray bradbury like something wicked
this way comes it kind of gave me that
sort of vibe about
growing up like boys growing up and then
there being like kind of magical stuff
going on it was just kind of like how
children deal with like the darkness of
life so this book very much has that
vibe
and i i mean i was really into it but
don't go into it thinking that it's
gonna be i mean there is the tooth fairy
is in it and the tooth fairy is kind of
like a monster
but
and it does like kind of factor into the
plot and factor into a lot of things but
it's not a straight-up like horror
monster it's a lot more ambiguous than
that and
most of it is based around the
characters and about
their sort of like journey through
adolescence and how they kind of like
deal with all of these changes and all
of this uh you know all of these kind of
dark things that are happening uh around
their life now i think this novel
actually won
uh the august durlith award for best
novel in 1997
and it was also nominated for the
international horror guild award for
best novel in 1998 and as i said i can
totally see why i will say the prose in
this
is
gorgeous
it just it makes you
it's just it's so immersive it's just
you can
and i saw this other reviewer say this
too it's like just reading the book you
can you can see it you can smell it it's
just everything just the way he
describes things is just so so
gorgeous and it's just so immersive and
it's very another word that comes up a
lot i saw it on in several uh unrelated
reviews was earthy
and he they meant that in the sense that
there's like vulgarity in it like some
of the because a lot of the characters
they start out very young they're only
like five six seven years old and it
kind of goes on until they're like 18
19. but it does deal a lot with
you know kids coming into their
sexuality how they perceive things
particularly boys it's almost all uh
most the main characters are boys and
you know so they're burgeoning sexuality
and how they uh how they approach that
how they deal with it so it is
i don't know if i would necessarily give
it to a young kid to read it's not a why
a novel i'm not saying that because some
pretty dark [ __ ] does happen although
you know i guess dark [ __ ] happens in y
a novels but i i don't see why somebody
like um like a tween couldn't read it
you know what i mean it's it is very
vulgar there is a lot of uh swearing in
it there is a lot of um
you know
sexual language
but i don't know i don't think i would
have a problem with like a 12 or 13 year
old reading it but you know your mileage
may vary on that uh because a couple of
the reviews i saw said well you know
there is a lot of bad language and a lot
of vulgarity and like i said um you know
[ __ ] up [ __ ] does happen in this big
time so uh you know just just know that
going in if you're thinking about giving
this to like a pre-adolescent or
something like that it's kind of like a
gray area i'm guessing even though i
think that particularly boys but girls
too um could get a lot out of this uh
you know what i mean because it does
kind of approach even though it is set
uh you know a long time ago it was set
in the 60s
but there's still a lot of stuff in it
that's really like relatable um to just
growing up in general
so you know but but as i said your
mileage may vary on that so the main
character of this book is a boy named
sam southall now this takes place as i
said they don't i don't think they ever
say what year but you can determine like
from context clues like the music
they're talking about and stuff that it
starts out in
in and around like the 60s maybe like
the early to mid 60s i'm kind of uh
saying like from all the music they're
talking about
uh so sam at the start of the book is
five years old
and uh he lives with uh you know his
parents and he has like friends and
stuff and they live in coventry in
england
now at the very beginning of the book uh
sam and two of his little friends clive
and terry who also i think live on the
same street as him or you know live
nearby anyway
they're kind of hanging out at this
little pond that they hang out at all
the time
and in this pond there's a big pike you
know like a big fish
and
on pretty much the first couple of pages
uh terry
who i believe is also five years old
gets two of his toes bitten off by the
pike
and
so there's kind of like the pike being
in this pond it's almost kind of like a
like a symbol of this is a very kind of
i don't know like a jungian kind of uh
symbolism there's a lot of that kind of
stuff in there not in any kind of you
know pretentious way or anything but
it's there if you want to you know pick
up on it of this kind of like wildness
or something that's like lurking just
under the surface so for a while after
he loses both toes
you know the boys keep going back to
this pond and seeing if they can find
this pike and like and kill it and stuff
uh but that's kind of something that was
going on in the background and it's also
the the boy's toes getting bitten off is
also kind of like a precursor of like
loss you know what i mean because
there's a lot of that going on like how
people deal with laws and particularly
the character of terry who has some even
more [ __ ] up [ __ ] happen like later on
after that little episode uh sam gets
like loses one of his teeth or gets one
of his teeth knocked out they're like
you know messing around as boys do so
basically he's like they talk about the
tooth fairy
and
one of the other kids says no you know
that's the tooth fairy's not real it's
just like your parents leaving the
quarter and then one of them uh has an
older cousin named linda she's a couple
years older and she says well there's
like a really easy way to prove this why
don't you not tell your parents that you
lost a tooth and then put the tooth
under your pillow and then if you if you
get money then you'll know that the
tooth fairy actually exists which is
actually a pretty good idea
so sam decides to do this he doesn't
tell his parents that uh that his tooth
fell out
and uh you know so he puts the tooth
under his pillow now he wakes up in the
middle of the night and finds that his
uh window in his bedroom is open
and he sees a little shadowed figure in
the corner of his room
now if you're thinking this is just like
some tooth fairy like some tinkerbell
looking [ __ ] this is not what this is
this fairy is very much like the old
school
kind of mythological fairy and the sense
of being
kind of like not a demon but sort of
like a trickster
in a kind of grotesque
and because he wakes up and sees the
tooth fairy
uh the tooth fairy who is actually like
pretty scary like to start with it's
kind of like
about the same size as a kid but looks
kind of like grotesque like with these
all its teeth are like filed down to
points and it wears these kind of like
tight slash pants that are like uh
mustard and green which i didn't realize
at the time until later on i was like oh
that's the same colors as the pike like
the fish that bit off terry's toes like
at the beginning so that was something i
didn't pick up on until later and i was
like well duh okay
so
uh so he sees this tooth fairy
and the tooth fairy who is kind of a
foul-mouthed
uh androgynous creature at first the um
sam's like he can't tell if it's a boy
or a girl because he asks it and it gets
like really mad at the question
uh later on like at you know it'll start
to because it can sort of shape-shift
kind of
but um but it seems like really upset
that sam has seen it and it's like well
now we're both in trouble because you
know usually
yeah the kids don't see me and now we're
both in trouble that you never really
find out like why
uh why the tooth fairy would be in
trouble specifically because a kid saw
them but it's just like this whole thing
so uh because he sees the tooth fairy
like the tooth fairy takes his tooth and
gives him like some money or whatever
and from then on
sam has
sort of like a weird
contentious
relationship with this
creature
he doesn't really have a lot of control
over
where it turns like when it turns up
but as time goes on and as i said this
is mostly like a coming-of-age story so
you kind of have a thing with sam and
his friends and their shenanigans like
all the stuff they're getting into
and then you know stuff going on
with the tooth fairy and you're never
entirely sure and this is kind of like a
spoiler and honestly
okay so this book came out in 1996. i
will say because i didn't even really
even read the um the blurb for this or
anything i was just kind of like oh
that's you know that looks kind of cool
like the cover and it got really good
ratings and i saw some
uh recommendations from some other
authors that i liked so i was like all
right i'll give that one a shot because
like i said it was on kindle unlimited
for free
and so i think this is one of those
books that
it's better to go into it not really
expecting anything like just kind of let
it i mean like i said i'm kind of like
that with all books but
i mean specifically i just liked better
that i had no idea where this was going
i will say don't expect it to be a
straight-up horror novel that's the only
thing i'm gonna say but it's better not
to know like all this stuff going in so
if you don't want to know anything about
it then you should probably like stop
the video and go read it but because i
am i'm not gonna spoil the whole thing
but i am gonna like talk about what
happens in it at some points so you've
been warned
but uh so yeah so
over the time like as these kids kind of
get older and go through all of these
shenanigans
sam's relationship with this creature
is you know becomes ever more
complicated and it's left ambiguous on
purpose
as to whether
this creature the tooth fairy is real
or is a product of sam's imagination
because i mean and there's evidence on
both sides because at some point sam
like his parents actually do send him to
a therapist
and the therapist um i actually really
like the scenes like with him and the in
the therapist thing it's just i don't
know it was like really funny to me but
he doesn't seem like he has any other
kind of like
mental problems he seems to have his
[ __ ] together uh you know he doesn't
have any other
you know any other kind of symptoms of
somebody that would be like
hallucinating or that would be this
imaginative that would make up this
whole quote-unquote imaginary friend and
there's also some points in the novel
where
it seems that the tooth fairy
can do things
outside of sam's you know what i mean
but it's kind of left ambiguous like oh
maybe sam could have done it but then
sometimes not because i do kind of feel
like maybe one of his other friends like
i think terry
actually it's it's suggested that they
see the tooth fairy like themselves at
some point
but as i said it's sort of left
ambiguous and i think that that was good
that that was done because you could
you could just say that the tooth fairy
was like a manifestation of sam's id you
know if you want to call it that or it
could absolutely be like a real fairy
creature that he has somehow become tied
to because for whatever reason
he was able to see it when most people
couldn't see it
so pretty early on and as i said his
relationship with this creature is very
complicated because at first it seems
very the creature seems quite hostile um
as i said very vulgar and swearing and
just like i can't believe you saw him in
his life angry
and you know threatening him
but then as time goes on he almost uh
the creature almost starts to like help
sam out
like at one point
he says to he doesn't say why but he
tells sam he's like you need to have
your friend terry like sleep over at
your house tonight um absolutely do it
don't you know don't like let that not
happen he has to be here
and so
he's like okay why but you know the
creature's like no just do it just trust
me so he does that and then it turns out
that while terry is staying at his house
terry's dad uh who has been kind of like
a little bit of a character he's like an
inventor and there's kind of this whole
thing going on with that uh terry's dad
like flips out and shoots his wife the
two other they had like twin babies and
himself so it was like a family massacre
and terry was spared
because
um you know because the tooth fairy told
sam
you know that terry needed to stay at
his house so
so the tooth fairy does like help him
out in this in some ways like that so it
kind of goes through as i said it starts
out when sam is five
and goes through um him and his friends
lives
i think until they're about 18 or
they're going off to college or
university or
or whatever so they're like 18 19 20 at
that point so it kind of you know skips
ahead like several years here and there
but the way it's done is like really
organic so it does kind of go through
their whole like burgeoning sexuality
thing because when they get a little bit
older the three boys start hanging out
with this girl named alice who's a year
older than they are
and she's a lot more mature
and it's almost kind of like all three
of them you know on a different timeline
sort of fall in love with her but she's
kind of like keeps all of them at arm's
length type of thing like saying she has
this older boyfriend and but she still
hangs out with them
so
a lot of it having to do with sam's sort
of like you know awakening sexual
feelings and as that happens like as he
starts to go through puberty and stuff
the tooth fairy
starts to change too as i said at first
it's just it's kind of like um
it's it's not really like either male or
female it's just like a creature and you
can't really tell but as sam gets older
it starts to take on more of a female
form even though it's still sort of
grotesque
but
another thing about it too is that it
can also like as he gets older it can
also change itself into
uh you know like uh whatever
girl he wants to it to look like you
know what i mean because it's like oh he
has a crush on alice or he has a crush
on his friend's cousin linda and he's
like well i want you to look like linda
and then he can like have sex with it so
so there's that and then the thing about
it too is that the tooth fairy also gets
jealous of like these other girls so
like i said it's this really complicated
relationship that he develops over the
years with this
fairy with this creature that like kind
of just turns up at inopportune times or
opportune times depending on what like i
said he doesn't seem to have any control
over when the fairy turns up it just
kind of turns up whenever it wants to
and there's one particular scene where
and this kind of happens this probably
happens about i don't know like a
quarter or a third of the way in and
sort of casts a shadow over a lot of the
remaining book until it's kind of
resolved near the end
but
they kind of the boys kind of get in
trouble for
it it's uh they they get accused of like
trashing this kind of like horse uh
whatever like a horse jumping ring or
something like that uh which they didn't
do but they get accused of trashing it
they get sent off to like boy scouts
and while they're at boy scouts there's
this other boy there who's like bigger
and older than them who is always kind
of like bullying them and [ __ ] and
they're off at these at this scout
outing
and the boy
pretty much is so like i said this is
why if you don't want your kids reading
it because the boy is uh for real gonna
like rape clive like he hasn't tied down
and everything and so
there's this thing where it seems as
though
the tooth fairy comes and saves
everybody like comes through there and
it's suggested that other people saw
what happened to but then some people
were like no it was just sam that did it
and so they think they killed this kid
for like a really long time and like you
know so they buried him and like stuck
him in a tree or something like that so
him being like thinking he's a murderer
uh is kind of a
a thing that goes on throughout the book
as well
until like i said it's kind of resolved
later on but as i said this is
honestly this is one of my favorite
books i think that i've read recently uh
it reminded me very much it gave me the
same kind of feeling that
boy's life by robert mccammon gave me
although
that was this one was a little more
fantastical as i said it's kind of more
i don't want to necessarily say magical
realism and it's interesting because he
does get called a magical realist
sometimes
but he actually kind of disputed that
he's like well he's like i kind of feel
like a lot of these types of books like
that i write
because this was uh you know i was
reading an interview with him and he
said a lot of these kind of books that i
write um you know particularly horror
novels or even dark fantasy where
there's magic in the world but it's like
you're fighting against it he's like i
very much grew up uh with a sense of
magic just being like a part of the
natural order of things and it not
not necessarily being either good or bad
just another thing that's there
and so it's just like another thing that
you have to deal with so
hearing him like you know or reading him
that he said that i was like that makes
a lot of sense with this because as i
said the the fairy in this is not
necessarily a monster it's grotesque
and um but it can be beautiful too and
it [ __ ] with him and does [ __ ] up
stuff like it plays pranks on him it it
threatens him like it hurts him
but it can do awesome stuff too and a
lot of times it's very loyal and it
saves him from various things so it's
just like this really complex
relationship that he has with this
creature
which is
i i kind of feel like the the underlying
thing of this is almost kind of like
and and this goes back to what i was
saying about this being very earthy or
being very like wild you know what i
mean in the sense of like nature being
this kind of like wild chaotic force and
you just kind of like
going along for the rider learning how
to deal with it like you know as you're
growing up and that that gave me very
much of this kind of vibe and as i said
like the pros is gorgeous i really
really liked all the characters that i
mean the characters were very very well
drawn especially sam who's like the main
character but the other characters were
as well they all had their own
kind of things going on like you had
clive who
was kind was a gifted kid and so you
know all of the stuff that goes along
with that where they tried to like put
him ahead in school and it wasn't really
going as well and all this other stuff
and then terry who you know obviously
when he was five or six years old and
his whole family was wiped out by his
dad and a murder suicide and so he's
kind of [ __ ] up and how he kind of
deals with things and it was just and
that you know all of the boy's
relationship with alice and
uh you know the kind of little petty
jealousies and [ __ ] like that and then
sam also
uh his relationship with his therapist
and him you know uh his relationship
with the fairy and it was just kind of
this whole patchwork of
just i don't know it was just like a
a gorgeous like slice of life
you know coming of age type story that
also kind of had a creature in it and i
don't know i just really really loved it
as i said um i kind of feel like i read
some reviews of this on goodreads and
most of the people like adored it um a
lot of people said that they had read it
a long time ago like back in the 90s
when they were younger and they uh you
know reread it again like now when they
were older and they said oh they had
like so much more like a deeper
understanding and appreciation for it
and i can totally see this being one
that you would reread like every few
years just like
like i said much like robert mccammon's
uh boys life which this does kind of
remind me of a little bit
but um so but i think the people that
didn't like it were people expecting it
to be
a horror novel like
something more like because i don't want
to say oh like stephen king because
stephen king wrote the body and this is
kind of like that too even though the
body wasn't really supernatural and this
definitely had supernatural elements
even though it's left ambiguous as i
said as to whether the whether the fairy
is real or not it doesn't really matter
if the fairy is real
because sam perceives it as real and
that's just kind of like where you're
coming from with it i think maybe people
expected it to be more like the 2006
horror movie which was called the tooth
fairy which i thi it's weird because i
was like they did make a movie of that
right i knew it wasn't based on this
book
but i'm pretty sure i had seen it and i
went read the wikipedia synopsis i'm
like yeah that sounds familiar i think i
i think i did see that i mean so you
could see because i think in that movie
uh the tooth fairy was like a was it a
ghost or like somebody that was like
collecting teeth so it was more more of
a straight-up horror monster type of
movie and so i think maybe people were
expecting that from this and this is
really not like that as i said the tooth
fairy is a creature and it is grotesque
and it and some [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
in this but
it's more like a dark coming of age
story like i said it's kind of more like
it's ray bradbury or somewhere around
there so if you like
that kind of thing then you will
probably really really love this i mean
i thought this was fantastic and
honestly as i said i'm just amazed that
i hadn't heard of graham joyce up until
now but i will definitely be reading
more of his stuff in the future i'm just
you know sad that he's no longer with us
he passed away uh several years ago and
that sucks but
um now i'm kind of excited because uh
apparently i've got like all these
this new author that i'm really into and
uh so i'm gonna have to start getting
some of his other books uh if you guys
have read any of this other stuff um and
you wanna recommend any of them to me
like tell me which ones are the best
then uh please do that in the comments
and if you've read this one also let me
know what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
tomes of terror book review i will be
back on the next one
bye